well unlike other recent presidents
George HW Bush did not publish a memoir
after he left office but the former
president did produce a steady stream of
personal handwritten letters including
this one that he wrote in 1943 to his
future wife Barbara Nora is on Capitol
Hill with more of those letters that
have become part of his lasting legacy
so beautiful to see those letters Nora
it is good morning to you and though
President Bush didn't write a memoir
many of his letters were assembled in
his best-selling book all the best
George Bush his humor his philosophy on
life and his love for his family were
all laid out and what are thousands of
personal notes wait'll you hear this
you'll know what I'm talking about
to understand President George HW Bush
just look for that familiar handwriting
dear kids this letter is about aging
last year there was only a tiny sense of
time left in a note to his children in
1998 the father of six reflected on
getting old I want to play golf with you
and I want to fish or throw shoes and I
want to rejoice in your victories when I
say be there I mean in the game in the
lineup viscerally involved in your lives
even though I might be miles away he
didn't save his words for just family
and friends he also shared them with
rivals it will be our president when you
read this note I wish you will on 60
minutes President Bill Clinton read the
letter he received from the man he beat
in 1992 your success now is our
country's success I'm rooting hard for
you good luck there was a kindness about
the man during his remarks Monday Vice
President Mike Pence shared a letter his
son a first lieutenant in the Marines
received from President Bush ahead of a
ceremony aboard the USS George HW Bush
congratulations on receiving your wings
of gold though we have not met I share
the pride your father has for you during
this momentous occasion he's most
heartfelt letters though I love you
precious with all my heart were written
to the love of his life Barbara he
shared one of them while speaking to
Oprah in 2010 know you love me means my
life how often have I thought
about the immeasurable joy that will be
our someday a legacy through letters
well I'll be there ready when you are
for there's so much excitement of the
head so many grandkids to watch grow if
you need me I'm here
devotedly dad isn't that nice devotedly
you know President Bush described the
book that contained all of these letters
as a heartbeat rather than as a
historical documentation of his life and
though sometimes the 41st president
wasn't always known for his verbal
eloquence in written word he said so
much I was looking back through in fact
not only just the professional letters
he wrote but the personal letters he
once wrote a letter to Katharine Hepburn
in 1982 and he said this is just after
she won an Oscar he said we respect you
so and I guess as a little kid I thought
you were the me out of the cat's meows
and then he went on to congratulate her
on her Oscar so many people were the
recipients of his handwritten notes Nora
never bad to be called the cat's meow
but I so loved hearing his love letters
to his wife Barbara Thanks the meet the
meow Istanbul I like that we'll see you
soon